now as abortion decisions moved to
individual states many wasted no time
with existing trigger laws now one of
those states is south dakota and its
governor christie gnome joins me now
governor great to see you tonight now
yours is one of the
few states
making abortion illegal immediately
with few exceptions your response to
those
including the president today who said
it puts women's lives in jeopardy
well laura let's remember that today is
a wonderful day today is a day of good
news something that many people have
waited many many years to have happen
that lives would be saved
um in south dakota we had a trigger law
already in statute and what it said was
that abortions would be illegal except
to save the life of a mother at the
moment that roe v wade was overturned so
as of today that trigger law goes into
effect and we are focusing a lot on
supporting mothers on supporting
individuals who find themselves in a
unplanned pregnancy or a crisis
situation and making sure that we're
connecting them to the resources that we
have
what is the approach
that your state will take
in the event that a woman seeks to have
a chemical abortion or abortion through
medication maybe getting medication in
the mail because you've heard
a lot of democrats today saying that
they will not allow that
to stop or be stopped by the states in
other words i guess interstate mail and
so forth uh what will your response to
that be
well the statute and the language that
we use will be specific to being
utilized for an abortion that's that
that is going to be referenced to that
does not save the life of a mother so
that's one of the things that i and
legislative leaders have been working on
we believe that we'll call into a
special session because of this decision
that came out today and there may be
some language that we want to address
during that special session and also i
launched a website today called
life.sd.gov
which puts resources out there in
information like this to those
individuals that are in these situations
and connects them to medical help it
connects them to adoptive services to
make sure that people really do have the
information that they need
at their fingertips but laura this year
in legislative session i brought a bill
that dealt with chemical abortions to
make sure that the people were going to
be protected from this dangerous
situation of getting drugs through the
mail and being unsupervised for that
medical procedure
will there be potential criminal
penalties for doctors and or women
who obtain
an abortion in that manner or who
conducted abortion contrary to state law
yeah our penalties are focused on the
doctor that performs the abortion
i don't think our message here today
should ever be on punishing mothers
i would like to see that we we focus on
making sure that those doctors who
knowingly perform abortions when they
know it's against the law that they are
punished and that's some of the statute
that we'll be looking at as we go into a
special session
uh governor noam uh we appreciate it
thank you so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else